what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday the 12th
the joint is brought to you by
stamps.com
i love stamps.com with stamps.com i can
skip the post office
and save money on postage you send
letters
you ship packages anytime anywhere
right from your computer with stamps.com
you pay a whole lot less
you get discounts up to 40 percent off
post office rates and up to 60 percent
off ups shipping rates stats.com
saves businesses thousands of hours and
tons of [__] cash every week for
example this weekend
we sent out 400 boxes
400 mugs through patreon how the [__] do
you think we sent them out you think i
walked them to the post office hell no
stamps.com we printed up the labels
we called the post office and they came
over and picked up all the [__] boxes
in a little truck it was tremendous
i helped the guy out i was getting back
from the gym and he pulled up
and me and my wife helped him it was
tremendous
how do we do it with the help of
stamps.com
tremendous you got a small business
stamps.com is a must-have
you print your own postage for any
letter
package or any class or mail it's no
wonder over a million small businesses
use stance.com so do me a favor right
now
use promo code joey and get a special
offer that includes
a four-week trial plus free postage and
a digital scale
where you gonna get that from nobody
uncle joey's hooking you up
with stamps.com stop wasting time going
to the post office
go to stamps.com instead there's no risk
with stamps.com there are no long-term
commitments
no contracts go to stamf.com
click on the microphone on top of the
home page and type in joey
that stamps.com promo code joey
and listen you're never going to the
post office again
the joint is also brought to you by our
family
cbd lion the [__] lion don't mess
around
whether it's hemp weed the kinesiology
tape
the gummy bears and raspberry orange the
tropical
they got capsules they got cream they
got
vapor pens listen to me go to
cbdlion.com right now
read up on the third party lab results
read up on cbn
the benefits of cbd cby
how they can help you and whatever
ailment you may have
go to cbd line right now read
learn get something if it's your knee
that help it's your elbow
if it's anxiety cbd lion can help you
as soon as i get out of the shower in
the morning i brush my teeth the whole
[__] thing
there's a container right there i put
1500 milligrams
under my tongue and i feel tip top magoo
for the rest of the day
go to cbd lion press in joey or church
and get 20 off delivered right to your
house that's
c b d lion it's time to get this party
started
uncle joey on a monday there you go with
cbdlinestamps.com and uncle joey's joint
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday the 12th of [__] july it
was a beautiful [__] weekend
and guess what it's a beautiful [__]
day to be alive
i got bad news for you my [__] devil
pipe broke
listen man let me tell you something
[__]
last night i was getting high after my i
have a little process
i do my little [__] cup of tea
regular 325 abx sleepy times you know
uncle joey
keeping the numbers low getting high on
it and then when i finish my little cup
of tea
before i practice my guitar i go out in
the yard
and i get my little [__] devil and
last night i was smoking my little
[__] devil
this is a great pipe by the way it hits
tremendously
it's perfect no carburetor look at this
[__] he means business
he's angry he's smiling he knows what's
on his mind
look familiar so i don't know what the
[__] to do
i went to clean the pipe out last night
and the thing just [__] fell the [__]
off
well that's the problem i don't want to
glue it and then smoke [__] glue and
then i'm cousins with sticky charlie
i go for a blood test and they're like
you got glue in your [__] system and
then
now it's another [__] problem and
then next thing you know they're talking
on me on my line
joey's smoking glue i don't need this
[__] so i got to figure the [__] out how
to
how to [__] like how to how to
[__]
put this in there i don't know i have no
[__] idea
but i was just starting to have a great
[__] time with this reefer
you know it's been great i i took this
break
i didn't know where i was going and i
tell you what i thought about
when i went to prison i was telling mike
when i got locked up
in 88 i thought it was going to be a lot
worse like that was what i was dreading
i wasn't dreading getting raped i wasn't
dreading getting beat up
i wasn't worried about the [__] food
i was worried about what the [__]
am i gonna do in prison when it comes
time to go to sleep at night and get
high
and how bored am i going to be without
the reefer but i'll tell you what after
a couple [__] days you got to pay
attention in jail so
i just forgot about [__] uh what i
was worried about and i
moved right [__] through it and i
never really thought about it as soon as
i got out of [__] prison i mean
that afternoon i got high and then you
know i tried to
be cute and [__] you try to
drink water and drink the certo and the
vinegar and nothing [__] pans out
but for some reason you know i was
keeping my
i had to decide like what the [__] do i
want to do do i want to snort coke
or do i want to smoke reefer which one
you got to pick one you can't
you know you can't you got to pick a
[__] flag i mean that's how crazy i
was you got to pick a flag
in between reefer and [__] coke i
picked the [__] coke
you know because i you know is only in
your system for 72 [__] hours if you
get high on a [__]
friday night you're cutting it close on
monday
you're cutting it close but you just got
to pray that your color don't come up if
you call
and there will be like color purple and
i was purple oh
[__] you got to start drinking the water
and all this [__] so
i just went with the coke and i was like
i haven't already done without the
reefer
for all this time you know i don't
really need it i need to coke a little
more
that's a [__] up concept to think
about but it's true
so i'm sitting there and i'm like
what the [__] how am i going to get my
because when i got here
i found myself smoking these [__]
poles or this weed and i'm like
i'm going through weed like it's
it's candy you know i'm just going
through it like i i
showed up with eight ounces and i went
through them in like [__] two months
it was like crazy
i'm like what how am i gonna slow and
this [__] is like [__] 35
34 how am i gonna slow these [__]
rails down and i'll tell you what i
thought about
when i was in the halfway house i was a
real [__] panty ass
i really was i i kept giving them hot
uas
and you know you do the first hot
they'll forgive
the second half they have a court
hearing
the third heart they have another court
hearing and they'll probably end up
sending you the [__] back
i got my first hot for cocaine they they
took some
benefit they take away your [__] uh
like
the weekend furloughs whatever the [__]
i had they'd take them away
i'd have to i couldn't drive you lose
your privileges that's what you lost
your privileges
so i kept getting into trouble like i'm
not in trouble like
for being a bad guy but i kept testing
positive for drugs i couldn't stop
[__] doing drugs i loved them
so i love i'm not gonna lie to you i
[__] love that cocaine
so i had to figure out a [__] you
know
i i was in there i gave him two [__]
hearts
and then i did some you know i did some
time and they let me go out
for [__] like three months and i gave
him another [__] hot
ua and they put me back into the halfway
house
and they said it's for a minimum of six
months
and i thought about it my wife at the
time was [__] pregnant
i'm like you know it's september i'm
back in this [__] halfway house
they're gonna hold me here till february
what the [__]
am i gonna do so i had two options i
could either sink or [__] swim
i said you know what if i do this i'm
going to do it right
i'm going to make them proud i'm going
to be proud and i'm going to get this
out of my [__] system once and for
all
so believe it or not believe it or not i
stopped snorting coke
i stopped selling coke i said i'm gonna
do these last six months
[__] by the book like the same way i
did the soprano film
that was buy the book i did i looked at
this last run at the halfway house
and i go if i go back in there and i
give him another hot or another two
hearts or whatever the [__] i give them
this ain't gonna end this is once you
get in that [__] system for people
who've been in the system
you know it doesn't end and if you keep
[__] with them they're gonna keep
[__] with you
so i had two i was already driving them
[__] nuts when i was out they
wouldn't you know they would come to my
house and knock on the door
and you're supposed to let them in i'd
never let them the [__] in that guy came
to my house ten
times not one time that i opened up the
door they were pissed about that
they were pissed about the foam in uas
that i was putting [__] in my dick like
powder and
pipe cleaner and toilet cleaner and pool
cleaner
and i kept zapping the test like they
knew they're like this [__] keep
zapping the test
so now like they had a [__] chick
watching me [__] pee
they had another guy watching me pee
they were looking at the camera they
were looking at my dick
i'm like you know what man i'm too old
for this [__]
i'm really too [__] old to be [__]
around with this [__]
let me do this the right way so i i went
into that halfway house
and i became the model [__] prisoner
i swear to god
you guys are go sitting there going no
you didn't enjoy i swear to god
i was deprived i was the perfect [__]
invict
i did what i had to do i [__] did not
get high
but i did get high and let me tell you
how i did it okay
i didn't get high but i did get high and
let me tell you how i did it
i cleaned up the coke i said no more
[__] coke
i got to do this for my wife you know
she's having a baby
i can't be [__] around you know you
always think that kid is gonna save your
life a kid ain't gonna [__] save your
life
you always think you the kid's gonna
save your life i'll do it for my kid no
you won't
you can't do it if you're not gonna do
it for yourself you're not gonna do it
for your [__] kid
so i was like you know what i got a kid
coming you know i really gotta change my
life so i just made a deal with myself i
said listen
six months no coke and what you're gonna
do is
you're gonna roll the tiniest [__]
joint
so i took you know instead of rolling my
[__] usual gorilla finger joints
i took a third of that i rolled what you
guys at home
call a pinner i rolled the [__]
pinner
and i had a garage and i paid 35 bucks a
month for i love that [__] garage
it had a punching bag an everlast
punching bag
a weight weights and i had a [__]
ghetto blaster in there
and tons of cassettes and tons of
[__] [__] in there
and i had my weed in there nobody knew
about this garage
nobody it was a hidden [__] gem i had
rented it i
got it off the newspaper and the the
girl was like i don't even live there
just send me like a money order once a
year it was 35 bucks a month it was
[__]
like stealing i had dumbbells in there i
would just go in there park
some nights i would park down the block
no i would nobody it was like my own
personal little bat cave
it was like having that [__] office i
had in la
it was behind the fence i would have to
go behind the side street
nobody would see me walking i felt like
[__] what's his name with the wig
uh ben affleck and the accountant
remember he had the [__] little
trunk in there with all the cougar and
[__] that's i had everything hidden in
there i had my scale
i had a [__] scale i had cut in there
for coke i had everything and nobody
knew about my little [__]
nobody knew about my little [__] hut
so this is how i got away with those
last six months of getting high are you
ready
and i swear to god i would basically go
to the garage
i would bring in those days there was no
[__] bottled water
i would bring like a [__] thermos of
[__] water
and i would take the joint i swear to
god and i would go like this with it
and i would put it out and that was it i
would lift weights
and you know what i feel like the first
week
10 days i'm not gonna lie to you i
didn't get [__] high and i was pissed
off
i'm like [__] this ain't working i was
tempted to take the second hit
but when you first go in there they piss
and they
get your levels and if you go above that
level then you test positive
with thc it would go up a little bit if
you ate like
those [__] poppy seed bagels or
there's different things that will give
you a higher reading
on thc so i was careful as [__]
but even though that for those 10 days i
didn't get high
like on the 11th day i would just go
and i was getting [__] blasted
off that one hit i always get your body
just adjust to it
if you don't have a whole joint you just
have one hit if you just have one little
roach and you hit it eventually
your body will [__] absorb that and
do whatever it needs to do with it
i swear to god i lived off that system
for six months and never gave them a hot
ua
but i had to work out four or five times
a week and sweat a lot
and i had to drink a ton of [__]
water but for six months
i kept that system and i [__] got
drilled i still remember going to see
goodfellas
and i would do the same exact system i
would go
i have a process for movies i would go
get little chinese food first
before and i always go to the 11 o'clock
movie nice and easy nobody's there
i would go by myself when goodfellas
came out i didn't give two [__] i was
going to see that
i read that book when i was in prison i
said [__] it i'm going to go
and i'm going to watch that [__]
movie i don't give a [__] if they know
they don't know
because you're not really allowed to go
to the movies when you're in a halfway
house you have to like
tell them where you're going and what
time you're going to be there and they
can't call the movie theater
because they would usually call you and
say hey uh is joe diaz there and then
they what are they going to come into
the movie
hello is joey diaz in here so i you
can't really go to the [__] movies
so i would hit it off and i would catch
him in the morning they thought i was at
work
but i gave them a pager number i didn't
give him like a work i said listen man i
work at a [__] car dealership and i'm
in and out of there if you call that
five out of ten they're gonna get me if
not i'm on the [__] road
so i had to go to court and get
permission to drive in the halfway house
to get that [__] job was a nightmare
but it was well worth it because that
driving privilege got me around the
daytime
plus and then i tell i said listen
instead of me having a [__]
a job whatever just hit me on the page
just call me on the [__] page and
they were like major we don't know about
that i go yeah it's a lot easier for
everybody i can call you right back i
just got to pull over to a pay phone
and call you tell you where i am and if
you want to bring some if you want to
because they would send people they
would send counselors out
like if you're at a job they would send
the counselor out your counselor
probably come to your job
twice a month unannounced so
[__] you i didn't want my counsel to
come i told him if you come
i won't be there so what i would do is i
had a friend you know
uncle mike mike kessler the crazy dude i
put on the [__] podcast
about eight years ago i told them that i
worked at the acura store
and if [__] mike saw one of my
counselors come in
he would call me on the page and say
where are you stop what you're doing
come on back the lady is here at the
time i had two counselors
i had a black counselor named judy who i
[__] loved to death
i'll never forget one day i was driving
illegally
like i wasn't supposed to be driving i'm
driving a car i'm blasting like def
leopard [__]
pour some sugar on me i never forget
that that was my jam then
and i look i'm at the light and i look
to the side and there's judy the
the black chick and i'm like oh [__]
if she sees me driving i'm [__] dead
i just sat there at the light and i
looked the other [__] way
and the light switched and she took off
and i [__] got behind
and i made a [__] right in the next
corner and that was the end of that my
other counselor adam
i had him by the short and [__]
harry's this [__] sucker
you ready for this he used to live
he didn't know that i knew but i knew
that he lived down the block from me
i was looking at his folder one day i
was in his office
and he was on the phone with somebody
when i came in and he was telling them
meet me at this place and i live right
down the block
and i was about to tell him hey i live
around the block from that place too
but when he got off the phone i didn't
say [__] i was just like oh you know
i just came to see you and he you know
when you're in the halfway house you
have a weekly review
and i would have to go see him like well
i had judy in the beginning but i had
adam
when i made a comeback to the second
time the halfway house they
they gave they gave me adam because he
was a little tougher
he was a jewish guy he was a little
tougher he was a new york city dude
and he knew what he was doing so adam
took me over and he's like you ain't
gonna pull what you were doing with
judy and all those people before i'm
gonna be on top of you i got the notes
from community corrections you wouldn't
open the door
that shit's gonna change i'm gonna come
to your house personally
whatever
[Music]
are you ready for this one this
[__]
was [__] the administrator from the
halfway house
some hot chick that came in my room one
day i was wearing coke in the [__]
room right
i got like an ounce of coke i'm weighing
on the scale and she comes in
so i you know
you guys know what a bundle is a bundle
is a little [__] thing where you put
coke in
but i used to make big bindles like so
you make a big bundle
like this
right this is considered a big binder
right and you [__] take this and go
like this
and then fold this and there's a big
bindle right so
i had the coke and a bindle and i took
the [__]
she came in but she came into the
[__] condo we were at i was in the
bedroom wearing the coke there was two
bunk beds
it was a seven man room so there was
four [__] beds in one room and then
three
beds in the other you started in the
bunk beds then you graduated to the
small rooms then they put you in a
three-man room
so i'm scooping the coke she comes in
she's like where is everybody i'm
scooping the coke
onto the bindle and all suddenly goes
like this and it just
bounces up into the [__] air there's
coke all over the [__] carpet
i'm [__] scrambling she comes into
the room i finally put the scale away
i'm sitting there she comes into the
room and she's like what's all this
white powder on the floor i go i don't
know
it's [__] the ceiling something's
like thank god the ceiling had those
white little bubblies
it was like sprayed up there like the
popcorn ceiling
that's how i got away with it she came
in she's like what did i do
and i'm like please don't bend over and
taste that [__] please
she walked out and i got on my hands and
knees i picked up every [__] rock in
that [__] room
i was scared shitless so she always she
always had like
she didn't really like me she wasn't a
nice lady i forget what the [__] her
name was
but he was banging this chick you know
you could see like
how they would talk at work and stuff
but it gets better
one morning i wake up because i used to
have to have to come to my house and
walk my dog
even though i was in the halfway house i
still had to come home and walk the dog
in the mornings and one more before work
one morning i go over there and i get
the dog and i'm walking i'm not thinking
about nothing
i'm not thinking about seeing nobody i'm
just thinking about my day
i'm walking down the [__] block and
who do i see
adam and the chick
walking out of adam's apartment at eight
in the morning i mean
you know four in the afternoon you could
tell me you're working eight in the
morning you're doing one thing you're
either [__] a snorting coke or you're
doing both
or you just get you know you just don't
go to somebody's house at eight in the
morning
when they when they both saw me
they [__] their [__] pants they just
froze they were like
i had my dog and i'm like how you doing
good to see you yeah
and then i didn't say nothing i just
walked away they went into their car
and that afternoon when i got to the
halfway house there was a note in my
fold to come see adam asap
i knew what that was about i walked in
there like
how you doing [__] what's going on
you know what what do you want to see me
about he's like sit down
he's like listen what you saw this
morning can't [__] leave
you know this this place will get in
trouble her and i
so i'd appreciate it if you [__] you
know wouldn't say nothing i'm like what
does this job mean to you
you know i mean uh i don't know
we got to scratch each other's back here
you know what i'm saying and he goes
what can i do for you i
don't know make my [__] life easier
here maybe give me some furloughs
i mean i've been here for a couple
months i haven't given you any [__]
hot uas
i've been a model [__] citizen you
know what i'm saying i mean throw me a
little love here give me a little break
put me in the three-man
room so we did that he goes if you don't
say nothing about me and the broad
i'll put you in a three-man room i'll
give you some furloughs
and i'll let you know keep doing what
you're doing though on your end
and i'll let the [__] last three
months of this be a paradise for you
and listen to this you're supposed to
it's like level one level two level
three
i always made it to level three and then
i got a [__]
ua always met up to level three and
always [__] up
[__] i made it to level four which is
like
you're allowed to drive you come in at
midnight
you can leave at six in the morning i
mean the [__] rules on level four i
mean there wasn't
if there was 90 people in that
[__] place there was maybe
nine people 10 percent made it to level
four
and stayed there if you were on level
for three months they'd automatically
like discharge you
like if you gave them level four for
three months they'd automatically
discharge
it was so good for me that i was
supposed to stay in there
for six months and it put me like in
mid-february and one day they came to me
and they said
you're done friday i was like you ain't
[__] serious
i'm like but no i started [__] with
them but no
i want to stay i want to do my time and
they're like nah you got to go
and if you're level four when you get
out
they automatically cut you you weighs
and a half so you don't take
four uas you take two uas a month it was
like [__] guys
it was like [__] stealing it was
perfect but i did those six months
by the book yeah i smoked under the
[__] limit
you know but it kept me together and it
got me the [__] out of there
so it's funny that i used that when i
was thinking about what to do
a couple months ago i'm like wow you
know my body just
you know the covid all this [__] every
time i smoke every time i was getting
high
i would get like a [__] sore throat
and i'm like i got covered so
between that the [__] emails and all
that [__]
that's what made me [__] give it a
breather but i tell you what man this
breather
has been the best thing i've done it
really has
i brought everything back to my world
with the edibles now i'm using them to
sleep
i couldn't even like i like the way i
can't imagine doing a line of coke now
like i can't even imagine what it would
feel like to do a line of coke i think
my blood
pressure would drop when i just die of a
[__] heart attack
that's the same way i feel about doing
an edible in the daytime
i couldn't even imagine feeling that
[__] way again
and i listen i got none uh you don't
meet dog i'm heavy [__] duty
i [__] did everything you guys saw it
you guys witnessed it uh i had a good
time i enjoyed myself
i was the king i mean there was a
podcast i watched that was disturbing
because they weren't lying it was rogan
and tom segura
it was a weekend that i went away with
tom segura and we went up to the
casino and we went to eugene oregon it
had to be 10 years ago
and he went on rogan that following
monday and told him i went on a plane
with diaz and he was eating edibles
and in that episode if you watch it joe
rogan says you know
if most people would say
that joey diaz has a [__] problem
with that thc
like most people would say that boys got
a [__] problem if you watch the
[__] podcast
i laughed because i knew it wasn't a
problem i had been doing it all my
[__] life that's why my
my tolerance is so high i was smoking
all my [__] life
when all those people because all of a
sudden in california when i got legal
everybody became [__] tommy chung and
i couldn't have it i couldn't [__]
have it you know me
so i even i even pushed it up a little
bit
like i pushed it up a little bit and
now i think about those times i'm like
wow i wasted a lot of [__] week
because i didn't need all that [__]
weed
this is why i look a lot better you know
there's not that many chemicals in my
body
i don't have [__] a thousand things
going through my body i mean
yeah i'm taking 75 milligrams a night
and i'm sleeping like a [__] baby i
wake up
with cotton mouth like a [__]
some mornings i
like if i wake up at five in the morning
i am high as
[__] guys when i go to pee i am high
as [__] i'm like i can't wait to get
back to that bed
and thank god i'm not walking around the
[__] streets like this
that's like i can't think of [__]
doing an edible daytime no more i'm
sorry
i even the weed like i miss the weed in
the morning i'm not gonna lie to you
uh friday friday night my wife
we had like a weird day friday had to
run around and [__] so i had like a
light lunch
at 12 i mean like an ultra light lunch
like i had three
cheese raviolis they were left over from
one of the nights
i i go why did you why would you save
they were big [__] raviolis you know
i go why would you save terry various
she goes i i didn't even know to think
about the offer
i don't know my wife is crazy sometimes
so i ate the three ravioli so it threw
me the [__] off
so i was [__] starving at [__]
three o'clock
and i'm like what the [__] am i gonna
eat my wife goes well i got some chinese
food if you want it i didn't know if you
wanted it for lunch
i ate the chinese food and i gotta be
honest with you i didn't lose just wait
for a reason i was [__] stuffed
then my friend called and he's like hey
we're going out to dinner with the kids
we're going to go get some cheese steaks
if you want to come i'm like [__] yeah
let's go with it but also i'm like [__]
i'm still stuffed from 3 30.
like i'm gonna pinch here should i you
know he's a cop and
other parents are gonna be there go [__]
it i'll [__] smoke a little bit and
i'll jump in the shower
to get that smell off and see if it
kicks up my
appetite god damn it but i didn't break
the pipe then
i broke the pipe two nights later but
i smoked a little i took one [__] hit
i went upstairs i took a shower by the
time i got in the car my [__] stomach
was growling i was like god
damn this [__] reefer worked i went i
met them i ate nobody knew i was high i
put visine in my eyes then i came home
that night and i smoked
and i think two nights later my [__]
devil [__] broke
unfucking believable i don't know what
i'm gonna do i'm gonna have to crazy
gloom
but i have to crazy glue it and make
sure it doesn't hit the little [__]
hole because
i don't know what it's going to feel
like to snort glue but
you know snort and glue is one thing
smoking it
must be a complete different [__]
situation i i don't know
but anyway i wanted to talk to you guys
about last week i'm happy
that you guys enjoyed the two podcasts
with lee last week i'm happy that you
guys got to see it
and i'm happy that you guys got to see
us together and see the changes we made
um i don't know how those podcasts came
across into your world or what you read
into them
but i hope they clarified a lot of
things for you you know
it wasn't easy doing those podcasts you
know uh
this is why i'm really hesitant now on
on searching for guests and starting all
that [__] again because i don't have it
in me anymore
like the patience that you have to have
with people
it's like the patience you have to have
with me right now
like this last week last week was the
first time i did three [__] podcasts
you're gonna see me on three podcasts in
one week because i felt bad i was busy i
was behind the [__] eight ball all
the time
you're gonna see me on dom dominic
lombondosi's podcast i don't know that
should be out in two weeks
or maybe this week i did ashley evans
from the ufc
and i did ryan sickler's podcast we
continued to saga
all the way up to uh i think uh
february of 97 when i got to the comedy
store
i had i've been so behind the eight ball
in this [__] house i mean mike was
asking me before
is there anything else that you want to
do what do you want to change what do
you want to do like i really haven't
thought about
it we've been so [__] busy here you
know
softball's about to pick up again you
know we had a little breather from
softball
she's at a softball party uh she had
went to a softball party on [__]
saturday
sunday we we met one of the girls and
threw the ball a little bit and hit the
[__]
went up to the softball field there was
nobody up there playing we just
[__] around a little bit played out in
the sun you know but it's [__] busy
around here i'm busy with her two weeks
ago i had her
for ccd camp so she would come home at
[__] 12
and there was no other kids around
because they were already in camp
so it was on me and my wife for [__]
five days to you know
do something with her till seven [__]
o'clock so
it's just been crazy around here and i
haven't even thought you know between
the [__] book
and you know we did ozzy's boneyard last
week thank you if you listened on the
sixth of july
jimmy and i i appreciate all the support
you know
i just been busy with little things i
got to [__] paint the porch
i got to paint the garage i got you know
there's so many little things
i have to [__] do you know but i'm
happy that i could still
that i i had to
i don't know how to say this i had to
take a breather
you know that a couple weeks ago when we
took that week off
because i had a shoot and i had a bunch
of doctors and my [__]
anxiety we had to get all that [__]
fixed i think it was one of the best
things i did
taking that week off even though you
guys know it's against
what i believe [__] we work every
[__] day here
it was good for me and it was good for
you guys i gave you a breather it gave
you a shot to look at what i was doing
and putting lee on the podcast i mean
for me it was a a growth thing
i wasn't ready for it yet you know
mainly had done eight [__] years
nine years i don't think a lot of you
guys understood that
that we were giving each other air i
think we were both lost without each
other
in september and october mike came in we
started a new
the joint and i started gaining ground
but i really wasn't gaining round i was
getting worse
i was getting worse i was getting worse
the [__] surgery helped me out a
little bit
but then i regressed a little bit with
my [__] anxiety
and uh you know i stopped doing stand up
i i pulled the [__] muscle in my leg
the muscle still [__] hurts the knee
is tip top [__] magoo i'm doing great
there
but uh i think it was time
for you guys to know what happened with
us in la it wasn't just a [__]
podcast
it was a way of life you know i mean
mike and i do this podcast and it's you
know
two three hours a week we shoot a couple
of videos
you know the church was [__] 10 hours
a week
every time i went to the we know the
church would start at eight o'clock at
night
but we would get there at 7 30 and we
wouldn't leave to [__] midnight one
two in the morning lee was there till
six in the morning after [__] time
because he'd get so [__] high he just
[__] pass out there i mean i
i couldn't you know i i couldn't get mad
at the kid we were eating [__] huge
amounts of [__] thc
but it was good seeing him it was good
seeing what he became last week
it was good to see that he shrunk we
both shrunk it was good to know that we
were both going through the same
[__] and we really didn't [__] know
it man
and you know i've checked in with him
every day since the podcast
we're better than ever we're stronger
than ever
i mean he's gonna come on a little bit
more from now on like once every other
month
i'm gonna start doing his podcast and
we're gonna keep this
journey [__] going man so i'm happy
that you guys
had a [__] uh enjoyed it a lot of you
guys were like
a lot of you guys reached out and i'm
happy that
you got to know the truth you know what
was going on what wasn't going on
with dear friends we did a great job and
sometimes just time listen i'm very
happy now
i am it's been rough to get to this
place
but i finally did it you know when i
when i got off the plane i didn't know
what what my expectations were
and it i didn't know what people's
expectations was of me
and right off the bat i got thrown into
the walls with my old friends and
you know i got threatened by one of them
a 40-year friend to [__] threaten me
just i woke up one day i came downstairs
and
there was a [__] text i called him
back and he threatened me
and i'm like what the [__] is going on
then i had another friend of mine
[__] go off the reservation
so it was kind of rough for me in the
beginning i was
just trying to get myself through murky
[__] waters
thank god for the florentines you know
thank god for
the people across the street the pumas
thank god for christina and steve thank
god for
all these people that came into our
lives and
took away a little bit of this [__]
boredom we made a lot of friends since
we've been here
uh when i got here i had some friends
that had expectations of me
and i had to let them off the [__]
hook and tell them that's not who i am
anymore
you know there was people that wanted to
show up here without [__] calling
i have a daughter now that's not who i
am anymore so
all that stuff cleared up i got all that
stuff adjusted some people's feelings
got hurt
some people's got blood hurt but i can't
i can't help you i
i have my own family and i have my own
problems i'm 58 [__] years old
we're not 20 years he you know we're not
20 and nobody's [__] going to studio
54.
i got responsibilities so i think a lot
of people got upset with me
or had different expectations and you
know what they're gone now
the other night thursday night i was uh
i had plans i was well i never i didn't
have plans thursday night
i was busy thursday i went to the gym
and then me and my wife had to go look
at something and mercy
and we were going to go to eat some we
had some oh she had kickboxing thursday
night and thursday night to late night
it's like [__] uh thursday night is
like a
6 30 night quarter 7 then we usually
just get dinner out
we just meet at a chicken place or
something or a burger place and we just
get dinner out but thursday afternoon i
got a call
from uh a friend of mine the guy
dave baton he owns db orthopedics
that's where i did my pt therapy i've
known david
since we were 17
you know he was 17 i've known david 16.
uh he called out of the blue and he goes
what are you doing tonight for dinner do
you want to go to osteria and i'm like
the osteria has a bocce ball court in
the back
my friends go there and they're like do
you want to go that's supposed to be
great italian food i'm like
i'm not doing anything let me just check
with my wife see what she's doing
and i just wanted to get clearance just
to make sure she could you know
it's my job to take mercy to kick boxing
so
i asked my wife i go listen one of my
friends called and said if i wanted to
go to dinner
you know i don't know what he's going
through whatever what do you think and
she goes i think you need a night out
with
with your friend you know go ahead go
jimmy was
working in the city he was at caroline's
i go you know what
there's nobody around i was going to
call jimmy but he was at caroline's i go
let me just go
eat with my friend dave you know
i'm getting i we ran some errands i come
back [__] home
and my wife leaves to take
mercy and i'm put i put a pair of jeans
on a nice shirt on
and all sudden one of my other buddies
the gear
text me and he goes hey are you
showing up and i'm like are you going to
and he goes yeah i'm down here right now
i'm about eight minutes away from the
restaurant i'll see you there
and [__] on the way to the restaurant
it was like
15 minute 20 minute drive i [__]
pulled in
when i'm in there i got another car and
it's a different it's mercy's godfather
and he goes are you here yet like what
the [__] is this you're coming to 82
you're coming
all the way down here because he lives
all the way [__]
up by alpine up there in new jersey i'm
like you're coming down here too yeah he
goes i got that day off
i wanted to go for a ride you know
stretch out and see some friends so
i'll meet you at the restaurant i was
like i'm [__] shocked it was [__]
tremendous i walked in three of them
were there
i didn't drink of course i had a [__]
boring water you know me
even the bartender looked at me like
what water
i go i can't [__] drink i died last
time i drank alcohol
i got a [__] reaction i just drink
water i go put a lime in there
so these people don't know i'm a [__]
loser they think it's a vodka with some
ice in it
we sat down guys we had a [__] great
dinner
it was something that i really [__]
needed
these three guys uh
we have a 40 year history i mean
these four got three guys i went to
dinner with
we're at a dinner i was at
in 1993 when i came back here
to do stand-up for nine months
my friends said you want to go out to
dinner and these guys met up with us
there was about
eight of us we went to a restaurant in
munaki called segovia
[__] tremendous it's portuguese food
with the lobster tails and the [__]
big steak
we went up there and it was about eight
of us we caused to [__] havoc
but i remember these three guys being at
the table
and they were grilling me about stand-up
comedy like you really gonna be a
[__] comic you've been doing it for
two years get the [__] out of here
like you know these are your friends
these like they weren't
negative they were like come on you're
really gonna do this [__] and i'm like
yeah
so it was really funny to go to dinner
with them the night and they were asking
me about stand up and i'm like you know
what
i just uh i'm just taking a breather you
know and they're like we don't
how do you [__] take a breather from
stand up and i go of course i go
remember you guys are with me in 1993.
that's 28 [__] years ago january of
we all went out to dinner two of the
guys died from that night rest in peace
it was done for uh my brother that his
wife died was at that dinner up there
another brother of ours stinky was at
that [__] dinner
he's uh you know he's married now he's
got his kids and [__]
there was like eight of us but those
three guys were there
and it was really you know they started
asking me about my career and stand up
and
like they don't know anything i mean
honestly they're so [__] busy in
their lives they don't know much about
i mean they've heard of the sopranos but
they know like one of the guys said i
saw the trailer
and it looks great you know we're really
[__] proud of you
and i'll tell you what man between lee's
podcast
and that dinner it's the name of this
podcast today you know what the name of
this podcast is today
just what i needed remember a couple
weeks ago we did the cars candio
but about six months ago i did the car's
first album on
album of the week on patreon just what i
needed isn't that the song by the cars
he just what i needed
listen having lee on the podcast
and doing that dinner with those three
guys and we were home by nine o'clock
i mean we met at six we [__] ate
[Music]
we had salads
four entrees which we all split with
each other and then to close out tonight
we had a [__] tomahawk steak
with steak fries oh my god italian
spinach with garlic in it
unfucking believable you know i don't
eat that much spinach i don't eat that
much [__] but i ate
every [__] piece that night i didn't
touch the macaroni and cheese i devoured
the [__] spinach
and they had a whole [__] garlic
thing
that they steamed i kept popping out
each [__] garlic
one at a time they've got the steak
medium rare i hate medium [__] rare
but with the garlic clove mixed in that
[__] steak
it tasted [__] tremendous and the
next day i was blowing some tremendous
farts at the gym
i went to the gym friday morning and i
tell you there was a couple of old
people there
and i would go by them these were garlic
farts
dog they were there was this one woman
that i would just go close to
i was doing like these uh dead lips with
20 pounds in my hand just to stretch out
my lower back i opened up a workout with
that
but by doing the up and downs you're
also moving everything in your [__]
stomach
dog i was ripping some [__] garlic
farts on friday in there i would leave
the area and then come back and go
oh my god this is [__] terrible and
there were these old people in there
because
the gym might go in the morning it's
older people
and then if you go back it closes from
12 to like four
if you go back i've only been there for
after four twice to ride the bike
because i've been busy in the daytime if
you go at four after four it's about
about it's young guys and hot chicks and
[__]
but in the morning it's just a couple
old guys just like one or two young
chicks
jimmy florentine goes in there
jimmy florentine was not there that day
let me tell you something
i was blowing some farts in there you
thought
you thought it's it smelled like [__]
the jersey turnpike and that
[__]
and i was going to different parts of
the gym where the fart was just settling
the fart would come out nobody was
opening the doors so it was air
conditioning
and the fart it was like going you ever
see star trek when they come down they
have like the [__] things the light
it was like there was a you would walk
into it and go oh my god this is
terrible and then i would have to go out
it was terrible i had like eight little
fart pockets in the gym
that i would walk in and out of it was
one by the squat machine
one by the fly machine one by the
[__] tricep thing
i even fought it behind the lockers one
time and i went back there to do like
[__] uh
sit-ups with the ball and i'm like this
is terrible
i came home i pulled my pants off to
take a shower oh
it was [__] horrible those me undies
had like a [__] brown spot in it
from the filth i still use me undies
even though they canceled me i don't
give a [__]
i still use them i'm loyal to me undies
even though they got mad at me and said
[__] it you can't do the part we're not
gonna sponsor the podcast
i still like me undies man so anyway
that's the name of the podcast today
just what i needed
i'm a lot better i'm doing a lot better
i'm happy you guys are still watching
i'm happy you guys are enjoying these
i'm happy you're enjoying these little
stupid [__] stories this is what i'm
going through
but because of you guys i'm [__] back
i'm back 95 [__] percent the
anxiety's gone
the drug use is gone it's all over we're
[__] tip top magoo
and ready to [__] go and we did it
together i'm with you you're with me
and they want to be with us we did this
[__] together man so
like i've always said the podcast
audience has always kept me in check
i talk to you guys and you guys watch
and you guys watch my every step
you see the guests i have on you see
what we discuss
and i'm very proud of that i'm very
proud that i got over this
what i was going through it was uh
something i'm really against
doubt and fear we've talked about it a
thousand times how they could [__] with
you
and i didn't take my own advice i let
doubt [__] with me i wasn't scared of
anything
it was just doubt i had doubt when i
moved back here i didn't know
what was going to happen i was going
into uncharted
i was in l.a for 23 years i had come out
of my comfort zone and i had built a
if you know anything about me i i'm i
build a comfort zone
everywhere i go i try to you know
make my life as easy as can be you know
i was telling my wife the other day
i told all my friends i love you and
some friends of mine look at me like
what the [__]
you know what are you gay about the [__]
for years i i've been
i think i've been doing this for like 20
years and i started calling my friends
who are tight with me my brothers
and i use a lot of love if you guys see
me on the internet i always
tell people love you love you love you
and that's because
friends don't when i say i love you
that means i'm not gonna [__] inflict
no pain into your life
i'm not gonna [__] you know
be a burden in your life i'm not gonna
[__]
cause any problems in your life i'm
gonna make your life as easy as i can
as a friend as a brother as a sister
that's what i
[__] strive to do when i say love a
lot of you people might see me
i just talked on my line he told me he
loved me he didn't even [__] know me
yes i do know you
and i do know that by me saying that
it makes me stronger and it makes you
realize that
with me i'm not going to [__] you over
when i say
that's why i get mad at people they say
they love me
then you know if a girl tells you she
loves you she won't [__] cheat on you
so when a man tells another man or i
tell another man or a woman
i love you it's that i won't cheat on
you i will never [__] embarrass you
i'll never make you feel down i'll give
you the best friend that you could
ever [__] have so it was good to see
my friends the other night and it was
good that
over the years i told them i loved them
and they got to see it the other night
the man that i became you know i was
telling mike
that the big problem i'm having with
this book is that
i got to write the whole thing you know
with uh
with erica and it's a lot to tell
i'm i i'm trying to read this book the
lives of jimmy page
you know it's a great [__] book but
i'm never gonna finish it
and because it's too [__] big
and it's too much in one [__]
place and that's the same thing i'm
going through with my book
you know i wish it was just narrowed
down
to these 30 years from 1991
to this friday this friday would have
been my 30th year
in [__] comedy this friday i would
but one good thing is happening this
friday
laughing gas comes out at [__] the
ice cream shop
so do me a favor right now before you
even forget
go to instagram and [__]
add laugh at laughing gas to your
[__] list of friends
you're gonna have specials on there
they're gonna tell you what stores
have uh laughing gas at and
let you know what's going on i think
they put a video up of me talking about
it
it's a great thing so that was gonna be
part of my 30th year anniversary
obviously i'm not doing stand-up i'm not
going to be on stage so it's really not
30 years
but it is 30 years because i'm still a
[__] comic in my mind
i'm starting i'm still writing a few
jokes from here there
nothing too [__] crazy and i put the
[__] time in
so that's what i wanted the book to be
the last [__] 30 years but
let's see what the publisher says let's
see what the [__] we can make it happen
because
it's just too much information and the
last 30 years alone
have been interesting as [__] on their
own i didn't even know that till
i talk to sickler on friday and i'm like
[__]
this stand-up story is great because we
were covering the beginnings of my l.a
life
when i got into the comedy store the
first month or whatever but anyway
that's good enough for today i love you
[__] with all my heart i'm
happy you're here supporting today
and i'm happy i was able to do the
podcast today this afternoon
i have to go to the [__] dentist my
gums are still swollen
so they're gonna [__] uh dig in there
so
i'll be back wednesday even if i have a
[__] bandage and i gotta talk like
it don't matter i'll see you
[__] wednesday
tip top [__] magoo on the 14th
i love you guys thank you for supporting
the church thank you for supporting
patreon
thank you for supporting the nfts and
this friday you'll be able to get
laughing gas
at the ice cream shop on ventura
boulevard in california that's where it
starts
and then we'll branch out from there
other stores in southern california
nevada colorado so on and so forth
uh that's it and that's that i love you
[__] with all my heart don't
forget to follow laughing gas
and now for a word from our
[__] sponsor jack
all right i want to thank you guys for
listening on a monday morning
whatever i'm here that's all that
[__] matters i love you guys
but the joint is brought to you by cbd
lion as usual cbd lion is my family i
love them i love their products
i've been with them for years they saved
me during the surgery
whether it was the kinesiology tape the
gummy bears from my anxiety at night
they got gummy bears with melatonin now
that you'll sleep like a
[__] baby but you got to go to cbd
lion to get them
they have the hemp they have the gummy
bears they got the capsules they got the
cream they got the tape
they got the vapers listen cbd line is
there for you to administer cbd
however you can get it and how it could
have been helpful to you
and your family cbd lion has helped me
overcome this [__] knee surgery and
helped me with them
arthritis and my other knee and helped
me with my wrist i mean cbd lion
is number one in my book listen go to
cbdlion.com
right now read learn you might
this answer might be with cbd listen to
him
you smoke it the cbd tremendous i smoked
it a few times
just to balance me out at night when i
can't sleep tremendous but it all starts
with you
by going to cbd line right now read
order preston joey or church
and get 20 off your order delivered
right the house who else does that for
you
nobody [__] uncle joey does the
joint is also brought to you by
stamps.com listen this summer has been
great so far
i'm getting back to enjoying life's
little pleasures now that i'm not caught
up with these [__] idiots and
instagram and
how many friends do you have on
instagram i don't [__] know what are
you bothering me for
i got softball i got barbecue i got
little kid parties
but going back to the post office is not
one of them me and my wife just sent
out 400 cups on patreon and how did we
do it
with stamps.com and you could skip the
post office
and save money on postage you could send
letters and ship packages anytime
anywhere right from your computer buy
print ship
it's that simple with stamps.com you pay
a whole lot less you get discounts up to
off post office rates and up to 66
off ups rates stamps.com saves
businesses
thousands of hours and loads of cash and
let me tell you something you got a
small business
stamp stop comms is a must to print us
postage
for any letter any package any class of
mail
it's no wonder over a million small
businesses
already use stamps.com so do me a favor
right now
go to stamps.com stop wasting time at
the post office
go to stamps.com instead it's no risk
you're sitting there going jerry what
are you what are you doing if you're not
on stamp
stamps.com you're slipping you schedule
a pickup
and the mailman comes to you you can
also take a walk and drop it off
yourself if you like to
but listen use promo code joey and get a
special offer it's monday
start your week off right go right now
to
stamps.com use promo code joey and i'm
going to
hook you up with a four-week trial it
includes free postage
and a digital scale with stamps.com
there's no long-term commitments
or contracts go to stamps.com right now
click on the microphone on the top of
the home page and type in joey
j-o-e-y that stamps dot com
promo code joey stamps.com
never go to the post office again i want
to thank stamps.com
i want to thank cbd lion but most
importantly i want to thank you
[__] for having my back on monday
and wednesdays
and i'm patreon everything else you do
like i said don't forget to follow at
laughing gas
at instagram to get the party started
and i love you [__] i'm gonna
fix this devil pipe no matter what
i love you and i'll see you wednesday
morning tip
top magoo stay black have a good day
love you [__]
[Music]
so
you